dans les trois dernières vidéos en
compagnie d'invités trop cool on a posé
le problème de la surinterprétation
surinterpréter s'est expliqué ce qui
n'est en fait que le fruit du hasard
ceci correspond typiquement à donner
trop d'importance aux données plutôt
qu'aux modèles ce qui a la fâcheuse
tendance d'augmenter le risque
d'apprendre des règles non généralisable
on a aussi vu comme pratique pour lutter
contre assure interprétation on pouvait
utiliser des méthodes statistiques comme
la validation croisé qui consiste à
ajuster le niveau d'interprétation
adéquat en voyant comment une règle
déterminé par un training 7 se
généralise à d'autres données que l'on
appelle le test 7 mai pour un théoricien
comme moi il ya quelque chose d'assez
frustrant avec la validation croisé on
voit intuitivement pourquoi ça marche
mais il est difficile de dire qu'il
s'agit vraiment de la bonne façon de
faire
c'est comme si on utilisait une
fourchette pour touiller le sucre dans
le café ça marche qu'on sent que c'est
pas idéal
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler de l'
approche de l'informatique théorique
pour comprendre le problème de la
surinterprétation cette approche
consiste à prouver un théorème qu'il
garantit que sous certaines conditions
tout ira bien et le théorème en question
dit la chose suivante si la complexité
des explications est une petite fraction
du nombre de données alors on sera
garanti d'éviter le piège de
surinterprétation est le corollaire de
cela c'est que nous autres humains
sommes très souvent en excès de sur
interprétations
alors ça peut vous surprendre qu'il ait
beaucoup de mots flou dans la
formulation de ce théorème d'ailleurs
tel qu'il est écrit là ce théorème est
faux mais il est presque vrai le truc
c'est qu'à l'école on apprend des
définitions et des théorèmes
méticuleusement fignoler qui sont
souvent le fruit de siècle de recherches
mathématiques et on vous demande ensuite
d'appliquer ces définitions une théorème
dans des exercices mathématiques
sauf que comme j'en ai parlé la dernière
fois ce genre de pratique peut donner
l'impression que les mathématiques sont
un ensemble de connaissances figé et
immuable
elles conduisent les bons élèves en
mathématiques à se comporter en dr john
alors que non mais non non non j'ai bien
peur que cette impression de rigidité
des mathématiques conduisent beaucoup
d'élèves a constamment faire de la
surinterprétation c'est-à-dire à
sacraliser la rigidité des définitions
qu'ils ont apprises voire même le choix
des notations qui ont été utilisés en
cours
et oui ça existe il y a des g un nazi
des notations mathématiques
ça existe
sauf qu'en fait les mathématiques
surtout au niveau de la recherche
c'est tout sauf rigide on l'a vu le
concept de nombre n'a cessé d'être
défini et redéfini dans l'histoire des
mathématiques
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous faire sentir
la vraie façon de penser des chercheurs
en mathématiques appliquées en
informatique théorique ou du moins ma
façon de structurer mes réflexions
mathématiques
celle ci consiste justement à partir de
notions intuitive assez floue et à
chercher une jolie reformulation
mathématiques de ses idées bien sûr va
essayer de rester fidèle à l'intuition
original mais on hésite généralement pas
à changer la définition des mots d'une
part pour lever les ambiguïtés du
langage naturel mais aussi voire surtout
pour que la définition mathématiques
rigoureuse rente nos jolies théorème
vrai et pour les docteurs john
psychorigide parmi vous qui douteraient
de cette flexibilité des mathématiques
je vous recommande ses excellentes vidéo
de number five et mick matt bidouiller
les définitions des mots c'est un peu la
solution mathématique pour lutter contre
la sous un terreau prestations et écrire
des théorèmes élégant bref revenons donc
au théorème que l'on voulait prouver ce
théorème dit que si la complexité des
explications est une petite fraction du
nombre de données alors on sera garanti
d'éviter le piège de la
surinterprétation est le premier concept
à redéfinir va être le concept de
complexité oui parce que par exemple le
concept de complexité de solomonoff est
inadéquat pour rendre ce joli théorème
vrai
dans les années 70 ce sont les
informaticiens vladimir weiss nique et
alexei shirov jeunes qui ce qu'ils sont
parvenus à trouver la bonne définition
pour ce faire intuitivement l'idée de
va'a punique et sharon ankis c'est de
compter le nombre maximal d'explication
haddock autorisé et pour mesurer ce
nombre d'explications haddock
il faut imaginer qu'on dispose est
originalement d'une sorte de chapeau
d'où on pouvait tirer des explications
haddock
voilà qui nous amène à mesure et non pas
la complexité des explications mais
plutôt la complexité du chapeau à
explications haddock et intuitivement la
dimension wc va être une certaine mesure
de la taille du chapeau à explications
haddock et ça c'est important à garder
en tête
au delà de notre cadre aux mathématiques
à chaque fois que l'on tire une
conclusion ou la tire d'un ensemble de
conclusions possibles il y a donc une
sélection de la conclusion retenue alors
bien sûr cette sélection à l'eba
arbitraire elle est motivée par les
données mais qui dit sélection des biais
de sélection
surtout quand il ya de la lea dans les
données et de façon cruciale comme on
l'a vu dans l'épisode 11 plus on
sélectionne parmi un grand ensemble de
conclusions possibles plus ce biais de
sélection sera élevé et bien d'une
certaine manière la dimension wc mesure
ce biais de sélection en fonction de la
taille de l'ensemble des conclusions en
mise à g formalisons encore un peu plus
sa notion de dimension wc pour cela
prenons par exemple trois points dans
l'espace des feature avec des les balls
qui sont des like ou des dislike et
supposons que l'on découvre les walls
des trois points au fur et à mesure 6
quel que soit le les vols du premier
point il existe une hypothèse du chapeau
qui explique ce les bols alors le nombre
d'explications haddock autorisé par le
chapeau formellement appelé la dimension
wc du chapeau est supérieur ou égal à 1
prenons maintenant un deuxième point 6
quel que soit le lait bol de ce second
point on peut encore expliquer les les
vols avec deux points à l'aide d'une
explication du chapeau alors la
dimension wc du chapeau sera supérieure
ou égale à 2 j'espère que vous commencez
à sentir là où je veux en venir
prenons un troisième point si on peut
expliquer toutes les valeurs des les
vols des trois ponts à l'aide
d'explication du chapeau alors la
dimension wc du chapeau sera supérieure
ou égale à 3 dans le jargon on dit que
le chapeau pulvérise l'ensemble des
trois ponts alors pour le coup le mot
pulvérisé vient pas de moi en anglais
andy shatter et seulement que je
connaissais et puis en préparant cette
vidéo j'ai découvert cette traduction
est pas mal de façon plus générale un
chapeau à une dimension wc au moins des
s'il existe un ensemble de des points
dans l'espace des features tels que
toutes les configurations de livebox 2
cd points peuvent être expliquées par
une explication du chapeau de façon
équivalente
ceci revient à dire qu'il existe des
points que le chapeau pulvérise la
dimension wc du chapeau sera alors le
nombre maximal de points dans l'espace
défectueuse que le chapeau parvient à
pulvériser intuitivement c'est bien le
nombre maximal d'explication haddock
autorisé par le chapeau à explication
puisque alors si je prends n'importe
quel autre point il existera un les vols
pour ce point qui ne pourra pas être
expliquées par une nouvelle explication
haddock du chapeau alors là pour
simplifier je me suis passé dans le
cadre de l'apprentissage superviser ou
les labels sont uniquement des likes des
dix lacs
mais bien sûr pour des cadres plus
généraux il faudrait encore modifié à la
notion de complexité en fonction du
cadre que l'on considère on peut
utiliser la dimension de nataraja la
complexité de rades marqueurs ou encore
la pseudo dimension de polars mais
revenons-en à la dimension wc et
illustre on l'a avec un exemple
supposons que l'espace des fidjiens aux
soins un plan de dimension 2 et
considérons un chapeau contenant tous
les classes if your linéaire du plan
alors avec un peu de patience et de
réflexion on peut voir qu'un ensemble de
trois points non alignés et pulvérisé
par le chapeau déclassifiant linéaire du
plan en effet quelles que soient les les
vols des trois points je peux trouver
une droite qui séparent les like des
dislike le chapeau déclassifiés leurs
linéaires
blanc a donc une dimension bc supérieur
ou égal à 3 en fait on peut montrer
qu'elle est égal à trois quarts pour
toutes ensemble de quatre points il
existe des labels pour ces quatre points
qu'une classification linéaire ne pourra
pas expliqué typiquement peut avoir une
configuration hawks or et on n'a vu
qu'une classification linéaire seul ne
peut pas expliquer louxor les
classifiant linéaire ne pulvérise aucun
ensemble de quatre points leur dimension
pc est donc strictement inférieure à 4
or on a vu qu'elle était supérieure ou
égale à 3 elle est donc égale à 3 de
façon générale si les explications du
chapeau sont paramétrés par un nombre
prédéfini de paramètres alors la
dimension wc du chabot sera plus ou
moins ce nombre de paramètres
oui presque intuitivement pour chaque
nouvelle donne et on peut ajuster un des
paramètres pour coller à cette donnée
sans toutefois perdre notre pouvoir
explicatif des autres données déjà
observé bon ça ses intuitions n'en
faites le calcul la dimension wc est
souvent plus compliqué que cela bref
vous voyez qu'on a pas mal bidouiller la
définition du mot complexité mais
j'imagine que vous sentez peut-être que
notre définition formalisé qui
correspond donc à ce concept de
dimension b c est quand même assez
proche d'une définition intuitive de ce
que pourra être la complexité d'une
explication mais juge de paix pour
savoir si cette définition intuitive et
punk ça reste de savoir si elle rend
notre théorème frais ok donc changement
un petit peu notre théorème pour inclure
cette notion de dimension wc le théorème
en version un poil plus formel dit
maintenant si la dimension wc du chapeau
d'explication est une petite fraction du
nombre de données alors on sera garanti
d'éviter le piège de la
surinterprétation on y est presque mais
il nous reste encore à définir
mathématiquement le concept de sur
interprétations
est ce que je vous propose c'est de nous
inspirer de l'épisode précédent avec
cette histoire de training 7 et est 7
souvenez vous n'avez divisé
aléatoirement nous donner en deux
ensembles d'un côté le training 7 et de
l'autre le test 7 et on avait vu que la
surinterprétation c'était quand
l'explication sélectionnés via le
training 7 se généralise mal aux tests 7
c'est à dire quand le taux d'erreur août
et 7 est beaucoup plus grand que le taux
d'erreur au training 7
eh bien on peut incorporer toutes ces
notions dans notre théorème intuitive
ça nous donne le théorème suivant si la
dimension wc est une petite fraction du
nombre de données du training 7 alors le
taux d'erreur
hôtesses 7 ne sera pas beaucoup plus
grand que celui au training 7,1 et
presque
il reste un dernier petit problème qui
est le fait que ce théorème qui est
maintenant formelle est faux je vous
invite à mettre pause 30 secondes pour
deviner pourquoi aller vite et pose le
problème c'est qu'il y aura toujours des
cas où le training 7 et le test 7 seront
d échantillon non représentatif des
données typiquement si on met tous les
chocolats suisses dans le training 7
alors c'est un petit peu compliqué
d'apprendre une règle pertinente le
hasard fait qu'il existera toujours des
cas où la surinterprétation sera
inévitable du coup ce théorème est faux
ce qui est un petit peu embêtant
cependant on peut espérer que ces cas
d'échantillons représentatifs sont rares
et en effet en statistiques on observe
que plus on est championnes
aléatoirement de taux n'est plus on est
quasi sûr d'obtenir un échantillon
aléatoire représentatif et c'est
justement ça la clé pour rendre notre
théorème vrai on obtient alors le
théorème suivant si la dimension wc du
chapeau d'explication est une petite
fraction du nombre de données du
training 7 alors avec grande probabilité
le taux d'erreur au test 7 ne sera pas
beaucoup plus grand que le taux d'erreur
au training 7
il ne reste plus qu'à être un petit peu
plus quantitatif ce qui nous donne si la
dimension vaisselle du chapeau
d'explication est égal à baisser si la
taille du trading sa a été égal à n et
si on appelle paix la probabilité
d'échantillonnage très non
représentatifs alors avec grande
probabilité 1 - p le taux d'erreur au
test 7 sera opus le taux d'erreur au
training 7 plus cette quantité là qui
fait intervenir bcn
ep ça c'est le théorème de vanik alors
pour que ce théorème deviennent vraiment
thuram il faut aussi et surtout une
démonstration du théorème est d'ailleurs
pour que la démonstration soit valide
faut encore ajouter quelques hypothèses
mais j'aimerais attirer votre attention
sur le fait que la démonstration du
théorème n'est pas toujours la partie la
plus difficile n'y a plus intéressante
et c'est peut-être dommage qu'elle colle
dont tu parle généralement que des
théorèmes et des démonstrations des
théorèmes alors que formaliser un
théorème intuitif en un théorème
rigoureux est vrai en choisissant les
bonnes définition des termes du théorème
intuitif
c'est en fait une très grosse partie de
la recherche en mathématiques
cliquez et en informatique théorique
d'ailleurs on a là un joli t om mais
c'est peut-être pas cette version du
théorème qui le plus intéressante
il reste souvent souhaitable de chercher
à simplifier le théorème à le vulgariser
en pratique ça va correspondre à une
petite discussion dans l'article de
recherche ainsi qu'à des remarques
informelle à l'oral en séminaire ou à la
pause-café entre les chercheurs ou
encore au moment de la vulgarisation du
théorème par votre serviteur si présent
en particulier dans notre cas les
quantités logarithmique ce sont en fait
négligeable
du coup même s'il est techniquement pas
juste de le dire j'ai tendance à ne pas
trop hésité à vous dire que le théorème
de créer un unique prouve en gros oui
généralement la sisqa même sur le fait
que je suis approximative quand je le
dis que l'erreur additionnel de
généralisation est au plus de racine
carrée de wc / n
voici qui me conduit à la version
vulgariser du théorème de vagues nick
qui dit qu'avec grande probabilité
l'erreur de surinterprétation est égale
à la racine carrée de la dimension wc du
chapeau d'explication divisé par la
taille du training 7 ou de façon encore
plus vulgarisée en pratique il est
raisonnable de s'autoriser une nouvelle
explication haddock que toutes les 100
nouvelles données sachant qu'un article
de journal sur l'actualité n'a
généralement qu'une poignée de nouvelles
données et en plus sachant que les
journaux ont tendance à répéter cette
même nouvelle donnée voilà qui donne une
idée à quel point quand il s'agit
d'actualité nous sommes sans doute
constamment en graves excès de sur
interprétations
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
donc eu pas mal de collaboration
récemment sur scène forum il voulait
vraiment encore une fois remercier tous
ses collaborateurs qui ont été a
toujours géniaux et je remercie aussi
leur type heures puisque indirectement
c'est grâce à eux que j'ai pu avoir de
telles collaborateurs sur les vidéos
sensor aujourd'hui une poignée de
vulgarisateur scientifique sur youtube
qui a commencé à arriver à vivre des
dons grâce à vous des cons
et puis ça leur permet de produire leurs
vidéos mais savoir permet aussi de façon
un peu égoïste personnel de collaborer
avec moi et je remercie énormément dé
type her2 ses chaînes et s'ils voulaient
faire une bonne action va aller type et
tous ces gens formidables joueurs
profitent aussi pour passer une annonce
puisque après demain je serai au
panthéon à paris pour parler de
condorcet dans le cadre de la semaine
des mathématiques au panthéon et y aura
une présentation de 30 minutes mercredi
soir l'entrée est gratuite donc si vous
voulez venir n'hésitez pas toujours avec
plaisir d'aller enfin à parler de
validation de croiser et 42 nous demande
aussi je me paraît vraiment de veillées
sont croisés de vanités sont simples
alors il faut savoir que le concept de
validation croisés en tout cas d'après
wikipedia est assez floue et assez mal
défini et en effet il ya pas mal de
variantes complet l'imaginer je pense
que l'idée vraiment importantes et
centrales cédées d'avoir un échantillon
d'entraînement qui va nous permettre
d'essayer de trouver des règles et
surtout de tester la généralisation de
ces règles à d'autres données qui
n'étaient pas parmi les données
d'entraînement
on parle parfois de donner in saint paul
à l'intérieur de l'échantillon
d'entraînement et de donner à 900 volts
et je pense que c'est assez fière
importants y compris en pratique pour
nous autres humains
j'envoie précédente 8 et des règles à
partir de choses qu'on observe est
souvent très utile d'essayer de tester
si ces règles vont bel et bien se
généraliser et pour cela il faut
absolument les communautés à des données
qui sont 1 920 tonnes qui fera ne fait
la remarque que même s'il comprend
l'explication de pourquoi est-ce que le
sophisme du parieur est un parieur il a
du mal à se convaincre un petit moment
que en effet ce 9e lancé en tout cas si
les essais sont parfaitement indépendant
ne sera pas influencée par les huit
précédents et je pense que c'est
absolument génial de se rendre compte
que notre intuition ne fonctionne pas en
cohérence entre nos traditions et la
théorie mathématique
ça permet de se rendre compte des
limites de notre intuition et du fait
que notre intuition est victime de
beaucoup d'illusions ils vous envoient
notamment vers la vidéo de monsieur
fillon qui explique pourquoi est-ce que
penser que le mois existe c'est quelque
chose
monfort intuitivement et du coup c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement dur a rejeté
quand bien même il pourrait en fait ne
s'agir que d'une illusion ne serait pas
très différente des illusions d'optique
façon plus générale je pense que ce
genre d'exemple permet de se rendre
compte que notre intuition vraiment à
délimiter de se rendre compte surtout
des limites de notre intrusion
ça permet d' un peu de mieux comprendre
l'étendue de notre ignorance et
l'étendue de l'ignorance de l'autre
intuition ce qui peut permettre
notamment de se dire que ben finalement
l'intuition on peut pas tant ils faire
confiance que la vie notamment des
modèles mathématiques ou la vie d'une
personne plus informés que nous et peut
être beaucoup plus fiable que notre
intuition à charge nous propose un
protocole pour que sachant qu'une pièce
est tombée 8 x 2 faces estimer la
probabilité qui avait tombé encore sur
place il propose la chose suivante faut
attirer un nombre au hasard entre 0 et
qui va être la pro a et épais d'avoir un
face et ensuite à partir de cette
probabilité p on va simuler huit lancers
et 6 et 8 ans et donne face alors on va
mettre la pro btp qu'on avait tiré en
mémoire et on répète cette expérience de
pensée encore et encore donc petit à
petit notre ensemble de valeurs paix qui
ont été retenus va augmenter et quand il
y en a suffisamment on peut à ce
moment-là prendre la moyenne des valeurs
peut calculer car on obtient l'or 0,9
comme la connexion de la place est en
effet ses calculs la sont exactement les
calculs de la place pour cinq ans n'ont
pas tout à fait à l'aise logique
en tout cas la philosophie du
bannissement fait c'en est très très
proche pour en savoir plus sur le baiser
isme d'ailleurs je vous recommande les
excès en vidéo de ce qui suppose sujet
kresic la dernière vidéo d'hygiène
mentale qui explique très bien les
rudiments de la philosophie parisienne
même si comme vous vous en doutez encore
beaucoup plus à dire
et quelque chose me dit que christophe
est d'ailleurs en train de préparer
toute une série de vidéos pour aller
plus loin
monsieur maxime demande s'il est
possible de sauvegarder les règles
déduites d'un premier training et
peut-être qu'on peut les affirmer
ensuite avec un second training alors en
fait bien souvent le cadre classique du
machine learning pro pas forcément
exactement ça rend compte mais des
évolutions un peu plus modernes
notamment à l'algorithme la décence de
gradient stochastique dont on reparlera
sur cette toile permet une certaine
forme de progression de praticiens déjà
au fur et à mesure mais pour un bail
gyan
la bonne façon de faire cela correspond
vraiment fait la sq est au coeur de la
philosophie parisienne et je vous
renvoie notamment vers vidéo de
christophe pour avoir une intuition de
ce que ça veut dire c'est que la
protéger cumulatif et qu'on affine en
fait à tout instant en fonction des
nouvelles données qu'on observe nos
croyances qui font honte était
typiquement bref tout ça pour dire que
cette idée d'apprentissage cumulatif
en fait c'est exactement le cadre de
l'apprentissage real se dire et c'est
aussi le cadre fondamental de dubai et
dieni gr kickoff pose de questions qui
n'ont rien à voir je vais arrêter sur la
deuxième question qui demande d'eau s'il
est possible de déduire en gros les
beaux axium des mathématiques à partir
d'espèces de big data des dix futurs
king toi alors je pense que la question
de la plupart des mathématiciens cette
question c'est clairement non mais en
tant que base est inquiétant c'est à
dire que finalement avec ce big data on
va être facilement capable de voir quels
sont les meilleurs algorithmes
d'apprentissage et d'une certaine
manière les algorithmes d'apprentissage
sont peut-être les bons fondements du
savoir et du coup une certaine manière
les bons axiome des mathématiques
voilà c'est une réflexion un peu
philosophique que je fais là et c'est
absolument pas juste mais je pense que
c'est une réflexion qui est loin d'être
stupide et j'aurais tendance à parier
que c'est une réflexion qui finira par
donner largement raison aux belges à
nice mme faye a comparé l'intelligence
des intelligences artificielles et des
humains et faire remarquer que
contrairement aux artisans savent bien
il semble qu lui ment et besoin de
beaucoup moins d'exemple en fait on peut
quantifier la quantité d'informations de
data auquel l'humain a eu accès au cours
de toute sa vie
et cette quantité d'informations et en
fait absolument énorme imaginez qu'à
chaque seconde tous mes sens en fait tu
m'envoies de l'information alors qu' a
priori pas vraiment sous la forme de 0
et de 1 en fait la première théorie de
l'information elle est équivalente une
série d 0 et 2 1 et donc d'une certaine
manière le corps mais en fait en
constant apprentissage de tout son
environnement et il fait vraiment de
l'analyse de big data autrement dit
comme le fait remarquer psycho gore
énormément de données pour une machine
correspond à dire beaucoup d'expérience
pour un être humain et ça ça correspond
exactement raisonnement de turing 1950
dans son fameux article je vous renvoie
vers les vidéos précédentes pour en
savoir plus et ça veut aussi dire que
pau kuni advienne intelligente
il faut absolument qu'elle arrive d'une
certaine manière à tirer le meilleur de
toute son expérience
autrement dit ça suggère encore une fois
qu'il faudra un apprentissage cumulatif
au hasard comme le bail zanis oui je
vous avais dit qu'on ne parle pas de
paysagisme dans cette série mais en fait
c'est très difficile de parler tous ces
sujets sans au moins mentionné le terme
bézian j'espère que j'avais mais cette
vidéo que ça nous a permis de comprendre
un peu plus comment fonctionne en fait
la recherche notamment en mathématiques
appliquées et en informatique théorique
voire de façon plus générale quelle est
la nature des mathématiques et en quoi
l'apprentissage mathématiques est très
différent de la recherche en
mathématiques
d'ailleurs pour cette vidéo j'ai été
inspiré par une excellente vidéo de
gigot et cole parlent d logarithme parce
que typiquement quand on apprend les
logarithmes à l'école on a l'impression
que ça a toujours existé accepte
toujours été comme ça alors que la
notion de logarithmes a émis beaucoup de
temps à être inventées notamment son nom
résonne d'un point de vue arithmétique
on va vous dire des définitions du mot
logarithme qui sont pas à la définition
classique et que l'école et à ce moment
il est intéressant de voir comment que
bidouiller la définition du mot
logarithme pour prendre l'avis des
finitions qui convient le mieux de les
servir et c'est ce qui explique le très
bien écrits directs dans cette
compression priant quoi l'enseignement
du fait qu'on a le droit de bidouiller
été finition des mots mathématiques et
quelque chose en fait extrêmement
important d'un point de vue pédagogique
qu'elle joue et ans
la prochaine fois on va parler d'un
autre concept important de
l'informatique théorique qui est
l'apprentissage probablement
approximativement correct ou
apprentissage pack tricorps qui est un
petit peu le cadre d'un petit sage qui a
un peu gagné les crédences des ferchaux
informatique urique vous payer beaucoup
de gens qui allaient me raisonner par
rapport au concept d'apprentissage
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
laquelle a commenté à la partager pensez
à vous abonner pour une économie culture
épisodes de mercy est hyper important et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois je rallie mais ça serait quand même
beaucoup plus super six le hyaric de la
fois baisse était toujours le rythme de
la course le logarithme de bay est émise
et oui mais en fait c'est pas le diable
l'idée que la première des lois et plus
harmonieuse de la deuxième était déjà
pas quelque chose d'évident des guides
entoure et donc ça c'est ça c'est
quelque chose peut-être un peu peut-être
les gens qui jamais ne verront que c'est
plus beau c'est plus lisse c'est plus
d'avoir la somme de logarithmes le gall
du produit qu'il a sablé le gars est
plutôt que d'avoir à -1
le boulet que jamais au pied quand
j'étais avec les maths en jean c'est
qu'ils avaient quelques élèves de
terminale qui avait déjà vu le vrai
logarithme et qui était complètement
perturbé par l'idée qu' un faux
logarithme la deuxième le gars il est
alors quand même après qu'ils avaient
accepté de jouer le jeu et de se dire
ben voilà il ya ce logo rythme bizarre
avec le moins d'un là le moment on leur
a dit maintenant il faudrait revenir
qu'il faudra essayer d'inventer mieux
alors là il était complètement perdu 7
donc c'est une des difficultés c'est que
c'est plus facile de parler bagarre il
ya des gens dont jamais entendu parler
de bright cas des gens qui se croient
savons pas ce qu'ils connaissent le
logar et or à l équilibre du mal à jouer
devant des règles un peu google via une
clé space age of touch of class i find
it is only one